The last part of graphing an inequality is figuring our which region to shade.
We could either shade this top region, region 1, or this lower region, region 2.
One of these has to be correct. To figure it out, we can use a test point. We
can choose any point in one of the regions to determine whether or not it makes
the inequality true. I want to make sure I don't choose a point along this line.
Because these points have been excluded. It's dashed. The origin is usually a
great point to check. It's zeroes, and it's easy to plug in. So you check it,
and determine. Should we shade region 1 or region 2? If 0,0 makes a true
statement here, we want region 2. If 0, 0 doesn't make a true statement in this
inequality, then we want region 1.